or vous êtes sandrine est mis à chanter
c'est sur instagram que les boutiques de
tours vont faire leur calendrier de
l'avent une initiative démarré il ya
trois mois par la blogueuse est mise à
part ça qui a repris la tradition pour
la mettre à l'heure du commerce
tourangeau je leur propose un calendrier
de l'avent donc le principe c'est de
faire des cadeaux aux gens qui me suit
sur instagram et au passage de faire
connaître les commerçants de tours j'ai
décidé de le faire local pour cette
raison donc je vais voir un petit peu
tous les commerçants intéressés par les
quinze mille abonnés de cette blogueuse
tourangelle les commerçants espèrent un
peu de visibilité à travers son réseau
social je trouvais que c'était une idée
sympathique que ça a aidé la visibilité
des commerçants et en plus c'était fait
par une tourangelle qui avait quand même
pignon sur rue dans sa ville et j'aime
aussi la façon dont elle parle sa façon
la façon dont elle anime son instagram
le cadeau du jour pour le calendrier de
l'avent sur instagram sera un jardin en
boîte un cadeau écolo éco-responsable
qui sera mis en valeur avec un simple
téléphone portable
j'ai une communauté qui est vraiment axé
sur ce genre de sujet local zéro déchet
essayer de faire afin de soutenir les
commerçants autour de nous donc je sais
que ça va plaire en tout cas hamas mais
et me soigne l'image de ces postes avec
une grande rigueur
c'est avec son téléphone qu'elle fait
vivre sa micro entreprise
aujourd'hui je vous montre un des lots
du calendrier de l'avent que j'ai
récupéré chez eli plus 1000 aux atours
zéro déchet c'est une canne au mit à
faire pousser chez soi c'est donc un
look zéro déchets éco responsable